we've been brought to this military
facility near the village of cell south
of Minsk about 200 kilometers from the
Ukrainian border and this place has been
the subject of feverish discussion over
the last 10 days because of satellite
images showing how quickly these tents
have been constructed and there was a
lot of speculation about whether Wagner
forces would be kept here would be based
here after the deal struck between
Alexander lukashenko and yevgeni
pregojin on the day of the Mutiny June
the 24th
we've been brought here told by the
ministry of defense that it was built
started building on the June the 20th it
can house 5 000 people if Wagner want to
stay here they can but it wasn't
intended for them no Wagner
Representatives have yet visited but if
they do they can work alongside the
Belarusian armed forces or will be fine
yesterday in our big conversation with
Alexander lukashenko the Belarusian
leader he had the following to say
we are not building camps we suggested
several former military camps that were
used back in Soviet times including the
ones you were talking about near
osipovichi if they agree it's a good
place but Wagner has a different vision
for their placement of course I will not
tell you about this vision
so the Mysteries around Wagner continue
not in Belarus his forces apparently
back at their bases in Russia it seems
as though no one is really fulfilling
their parts of the deal